hello and welcome to this video playing
bones and grant master Frank halts come
from Germany frankovsky should pronounce
it in a German way let's see how we have
played we never played a tournament game
but we have played blitz over the board
blitz in various regional competitions
let's see what we get ok it's going for
b6 it's an interesting line not as
simplifying as some others against
Bishop f4 ok I can take an hour Queenie
two hours like this kind of setup and so
it's always looks very natural to me ok
interesting we should be 5 i'm not sure
about it
I go as go here yeah Oh interesting this
night g5 in this position isn't that
good that good looks good but some
issues now I'm not quite seeing how I
defends him
grenade 5 g 6 i'm taking h6 Queen g6 or
Bishop g7 is probably best to Queen g6e
can still take on your 5 I can take here
though
black resigns yeah it was a nice tactic
here I mean tactic that's wrong a strong
word but it's it's it's an interesting
thing to to remember that motif of 95 I
think here he probably am he is okay and
he can play um yeah normal move I know
rook c8 c5 yeah by taking taking I don't
know that it looks a little bit wrong
letting the night yeah the night is
somewhat stranded there on age five this
doesn't have a clear way to go so I
don't know rook c8 c5 maybe now I take
die bisher basics I like my position a
little bit more here night h5 doesn't
feel so right to me maybe you can take
this is also an option take take and
then c5 maybe now but ok I'm better
develop yeah I can always just
centralized okay this is definitely not
working now g5 is pretty awful for him
to face it's too much hanging this is
hanging e6 and nh7 and many things are
like this yeah I'm not I'm not playable
check I don't think something like this
is pretty awful I mean I didn't
calculate that in the game but it just
not you five just should work and and it
does here check my stuff like this going
on that tag is some unstoppable yeah I
b6 is an interesting variation but
probably hear you should play em I know
rook c8 or something like that maybe see
5 or the capture this is also maybe this
is a valid option Bishop t6 like it's
very solid really okay thanks for
watching